so i get this question a lot how much
vitamin d should we be taking on a daily
basis
well i think we should probably go to
the experts right the vitamin d council
stated that healthy adults which i'm
still trying to find some healthy adults
need about 2 000 ius that's
international units okay per day
if you're getting little to no sun
other experts
recommend 400 to 800
iu's per day
now
here's the problem
that i need your help with okay i just
don't understand this
when we take vitamin d it's in these
units right here international units but
when they measure the blood it's not in
international units
it's in ngs per milliliter okay
so if you're deficient in your blood how
do we know how much vitamin d
to take because the units
and supplements are ius okay so it's
kind of weird i it's i don't know why
they do that but if we take a look at
the optimum concentration
in your blood of vitamin d it should be
between 40 to 60 ngs per milliliter okay
so if you had
20 ngs per milliliter that would be
considered low right
well let's convert 20 ngs per milliliter
to international units per milliliter it
would be 0.8
pretty small
but the question is how much blood do we
have
because this is per milliliter not all
of your blood
so we have about five liters of blood in
the average size person
and that would give us if we do the math
four thousand
international units okay vitamin d
so
people that are deficient that have only
20 ngs per milliliter
really have about 4 000
international units of vitamin
d
which is actually greater than what is
recommended there's some conflicting
information here isn't there
all right so just keep tracking with me
here because if we take the optimum
concentration which is 40 to 60 okay
how much
vitamin d is this in international units
well if you do the calculations it's 8
to 9000 ius
that's what's normal in your blood
so how are we going to get this
if we're only recommending
this
or that
that's what i just don't understand it
doesn't make sense to me and on top of
that
i don't think you're going to absorb 100
of your supplements estimates show that
you really only absorb between 60 to 80
percent that's in a healthy person
of these vitamin d supplements when you
take them if you're taking d3 not
and so if we're only absorbing 60 to 80
percent
and you took let's say 10 000 iu's
in one day
you're really only absorbing 6 000 to 8
international units of vitamin d3
which just barely
make
the normal amount that you need in your
blood so there's a big problem here
because these recommendations do not
match what we really need to normalize
our blood values and then on top of that
if you're taking these amounts and you
have a deficiency or you have other
problems like inflammation
or you don't have a gallbladder or you
have gut damage from past antibiotics or
you're older or you have insulin
resistance or you are obese
there are so many barriers that are
going to prevent you from absorbing this
vitamin d
anyway what i would recommend for the
average person is to take at least
at least
10 000 ius every single day
and on top of that get some sun if you
can
just to meet the minimum requirements
that your body needs and another point i
want to bring up is that vitamin d is
the
most important vitamin because it's so
important for your immune system to
maintain a healthy mood to keep
inflammation out of your body and not to
mention your bone structure your teeth
so it's no wonder why the great majority
of the population is deficient in
vitamin d
so if you're enjoying my content which i
hope you are
and you're applying this knowledge to
your health
and you have a success i would really
appreciate you sharing your success
story so click the link down below to my
website where you can upload your
success story so you can help inspire
others